you know what i got in here guys that
you don't have
it's a standing desk i got a standing
desk yeah uh we are currently at uh the
production offices of
some show nobody's ever heard of this is
called mythic quest
a different mythic quest production
office yeah this is um
but what people don't realize is how
shitty uh television studios actually
are rob what is this contraption you
have in your office um well i did not
have this installed clearly this was
installed sometime in the mid 70s based
on the uh
[Music]
technology
we don't make things that are that size
that only have one button on them
anymore
yeah it's a waste of space you want to
see what happens well hold on a second
let's describe for the listener uh what
we're looking at here we're looking at
like a rectangular
box yeah right a wooden box with a uh
black button in the center
and that's it attached to some sort of
like a chord coming off a very long
chord and doesn't this chord sort of
remind you of like an electrical chord
from your childhood yes yeah old school
early 80s very like uh it's going to
cause a fire type of course yes the
technology is
okay and
when you first found this box was it
mounted under a desk
um
i believe it was on the side of a desk
mounted on the side of a desk it was a
hidden away very dr no very gold finger
yes right yes so now this this person
with this mysterious button on their
desk
let's see what the button does okay yeah
so rob is going to push the button he's
pushing it now and
it is shutting the door shutting the
office
now
how many people oh hmm
we're sitting in this office
and saw that door closed
and got real scared yeah what did she
think
right
or he yeah well definitely well it could
have been he that's what i'm saying it
could have been it could have been
that's what i'm saying i mean look
i'm not talking about a female executive
i'm talking about male 1
even if it's a male executive yeah for
sure getting what he wants even if that
button wasn't used for assault just the
intimidation alone like you come in and
we're going to talk you're like so you
know
like i've noticed something about your
work and then
yeah you hear the click and the door
just
no
megan also has one just f1 i have one in
my office so
this office had multiple yeah
yeah it's two defenders
potential sounds um can we admit
something to you can i admit something
to you i love it i love it too
you use it all the time you wind up
using it all the time now do is there a
possibility that the button was
installed because in this particular
office
there were people that maybe
had a disability that made it difficult
to get to the door and so they said
let's just make it easier for the
there's not a lot of ramps though into
this office or anything no so it doesn't
lock the door i feel
that's what i feel we need to mention
that does not lock the door
now that makes a big difference there
should be two buttons there should be
one that closes it and one in the box
that's a lot of buttons because if you
don't have a desk full of buttons
like an operator yeah
and you're the boss you know you don't
want to look like the employee without
having to push too many buttons two
buttons took up a lot of space back in
the day didn't it yeah well you know
these days you can get buttons real
close together and they don't even need
to be actual buttons they can just be on
a screen no now you can just say things
alexa alexa close the door
alexa lock the door let's lock the door
alexa make this person like me
oh yeah you know what i mean or respect
me or fear me fear me that's what those
buttons are about yeah
hollywood was a shady place not anymore
no we sorted it out yeah we sorted it
all out everything right we got rid of
the bad ones well we sent them to jail
some some of them yeah some of them got
sent to jail some of them
and everybody else
some sent themselves to europe and some
senators
which is the jail of the world but
yeah europe jail of the world yeah i
knew you go to paris now oh no okay
but we anyway we sorted it out and all
the monsters are gone and now
hollywood's great
megan when's the last time you run it
ran into a hollywood monster
well i only work with you guys so never
oh my god don't cut down
give us time
yeah give us time yeah we'll get there
[Music]
so what do we what are we doing here
today well first of all we're here to
talk about uh the gang solves the north
korea situation
uh that's the episode that we're
discussing today but um in an
earlier podcast
uh i believe we had discussed some of my
uh wildest dreams right things that i'd
grown up seeing in movies
such as sinking in quicksand and you
know cutting open a bag of of uh of
cocaine and then putting it on your gums
and
you know and then one of them i believe
that came up over the course of the
conversation was kicking in a door yeah
yeah
right i think
megan you set this up it's very it was i
tried to get quick sand and cocaine but
it didn't come through but i found a
door
sinking and cooking
this is what this is when you need a
hollywood monster because because a
monster
the person who had that had the cocaine
and if they were truly diabolical had
some quicksand yes well he had access to
it he knew the right people to come i
want some quick sandal bro
i don't seek you in quicksand there are
benefits to working with monsters they
can get whatever you need that's true
you yell with the right person or not
it's the only way to get someone out of
a four picture deal just sync them in
quick
yeah
but the thing about quicksand is you get
to watch it happen slowly and the person
has the opportunity to change their mind
right so you can pull them out of the
center you're like
you know you're going down this is this
is happening this should call it slow
sand
yeah it's not something
it's not it's not quick at all it should
be called
why is it quick sand it's very slow
but but in the spirit of uh making those
dreams come true
and uh an acknowledgement of a moment of
this episode there's a door
that that is constantly trying to be uh
kicked open in this episode yeah try to
bash it open i tried my own home keys
which i'd forgotten about yeah i love
that that's a great joke
that was an adam stein joke wouldn't it
there's a lot of i don't know it was an
adam stein joke it could have been
that's great i think there's a lot of
martyr and roselle in this episode
they are
i was going to say are we going to
discuss the bamboo flute are we going to
discuss
we made some poor choices our hearts
were in the right place but the behavior
was wrong i think as the filmmakers we
made some
some questionable decisions yeah yeah i
think i think you're right i think i
think that's fair to say um charlie
you're a musician uh is that flute
called a bamboo flute am i correct in in
saying that i don't know i don't know i
don't know the racist instruments we
can't always get it right sometimes we
[ __ ] it up
i'll tell you what we got i'll tell you
what we got right okay leather dusters
dusters yeah hilarious doors marked
pirate mm-hmm this is very enjoyable
some classics i think
even you guys doing the the i know
judges was very funny it was when we set
it up i was like cringing because i was
like oh this is one of the ones where we
where we're we parody something and it's
gonna lock us in and date us and then i
watch the scene i'm like it's funny it's
hilarious it's super fun even if you
don't know the reference danny being
like no it's a no dog
it might
i got again i gotta highlight caitlyn's
drunk acting i mean my god uh her
heartland's drunk acting is fantastic in
this episode you've got some you've got
some moments that really made me laugh
hard in this episode too like your your
whole explanation of the
threat color
oh that was a real thing too yeah oh
that was the other thing it was a real
george bush's george bush's color-coded
threat yes alert system or whatever that
was called
uh yeah so we were spoofing that but i
love i also love how like you're yelling
and then you go and then and then you
know
k uh d says something about like you're
not gonna take over my talent show and
she's like that's already done and like
you just completely drop it
you know we're taking over the talent
show also how angry you are at her for
her impression of rosie perez yes
you're constantly like yelling at her
and getting angry and her at her in this
episode in a way that is just so funny
to me well i remember so this is the
introduction of the duster and i
remember there it's such a long speech
and i think i remember getting really
upset with myself because i'm trying to
deliver it but not but i it was so long
and i was just trying to get through it
as as quickly as possible to like get
out the information and i remember that
the glasses
that was like a last minute thing where
casey our our prop master was out in
front of paddy's and was like i was
thinking you might want some sunglasses
i'm like well let me look at him and he
showed me like a group and i just put
them on and i think the first take i
remember walking in with it and you guys
just started laughing and then from that
point forward it was impossible to get
through a tank yeah yeah that was good
that was a good that's a that's a good
look man that's a it's a fun look it's a
fun look the duster is undeniably
the most badass coat i love i love the
part where
you can't hear dennis on the other end
and you're just yes that is amazing yeah
would you call him oh yeah yeah yeah to
gloat and then and then
it's implied that he's like [ __ ] this
i'm coming over yes yes yeah and you're
like don't no no don't and then you hang
out with your wife
and then i'm laughing there's a lot of
good stuff in this episode and and the
twists and turns of the story are really
fun i mean danny jumping in in the
slo-mo shot which again
had that flicker so i feel like yeah our
version of slo-mo in those first two
three seasons
we never figured this out were we using
some different kind of camera i don't
know what we used for that do you
remember what kind of camera we used for
that particular slow motion sequence i
just remember we used the phantom when
we shot the christmas episode yes
then we must have been using that
phantom thing because we shot the
christmas episode at the end of season
four so you have to adjust for the
lights to make sure that they don't
flicker like that i mean i i i know it's
it's very it's very strange i did enjoy
the edition that i believe we just added
in post of the uh the six million dollar
man yeah yeah
that that makes it really work pretty
good yeah that's pretty good also your
moment where you're like uh
where you're like wait so you're going
to spray my fiance with water exposing
your breasts to the entire crowd that's
really that's what i'm talking about and
like there's some dicey [ __ ] in there
yeah but we're done
you guys get in trouble for it it's like
i know and it doesn't happen but okay
but you know the fact that we're like
it's what what a change in times right
because we we knew it's not like we're
getting caught off guard here and being
like oh man these guys are behaving
badly like of course we're like let's
set up a bunch of bad behavior and then
have these people yeah
pay the price and lose and that was sort
of what the show was and it's
interesting to look at it now and say oh
man that behavior is bad like
no [ __ ] no totally but you know it's
that thing that the it's the
wherever our meter is like when we're in
the writers room and there's certain
things we're like that doesn't feel
right that feels like it's too far
and i think our meter then was just in a
different place than it is now meaning
like it just gives us a little bit more
of a yeah more pause to even
yeah yeah yeah
i personally
um
want to get to glenn kicking the door in
really badly because i feel like that's
like exciting and fun and i feel like
talking about the episodes is boring i
think it is but then when i'm out in the
world apparently a lot of people are
listening to the podcast which is great
everywhere i go more people are telling
me that they're listening to the podcast
than actually watch any of the shows we
make
and they do enjoy us talking about the
episodes
and reminiscing do you find this part of
the podcast exciting i find it boring ah
it's not that i well it feel you know
what it is for me i sometimes feel like
it it feels like self-indulgent it's
like it's just like like like people
talking about something that they
already did and then patting themselves
on the back yeah and then remember that
time that's what the podcast is yeah
that was the original concept for
concepts
i understand the like uh
i will say that
i think i can see how it could be
interesting certainly
my interest in the
and what i like to do
align with the podcast where people
would be talking about the process
uh so if there was a
uh you know if there's a podcast with
certain filmmakers i'm i want to hear
every detail you know but that's me and
i know i'm a limited amount of the
audience here you know i'm actually i'm
one person but
i don't know yeah yeah we should kick in
some doors and that might get us really
going on something charlie before we do
though
we're wearing besides your orange outer
shirt or rust colored let's call it
we're wearing the same colors
this is like a charcoal gray similar
though
and your pants are black and mine are
black anybody who's watching on youtube
and all the listeners um
not only is this boring but it's not
even true well glenn is wearing
completely different colors than charlie
charlie we're wearing the same outfit
they don't know if they're they don't
watch you know um a lot of people watch
and i like that glenn calls them creeps
and i think we should just call them the
creeps well when you call someone a
watcher it just sounds creepy i'm not
saying they're creeps i'm just saying
when you call someone a watcher it
sounds great
like call someone a listener it's like
yeah listener right but i i i think
maybe that's kind of fun that if the
audience on the uh who's listening to
this in on the drive to and fro work
they're the listener and anybody who's
watching is a creep
i think that's kind of fun okay that's
the creep audience yeah all right wants
to look in definitely like try to
alienate as many people as possible
seems like a great idea let's see how
many of these creeps uh want to see me
kick a door in yeah all right let's do
one for the creeps oh all right for you
chris okay all right we're gonna try to
kick a door in in this office yeah we
have a door marked
i'm very excited about this guys
yeah let's talk about it a little bit
yeah
how are you feeling yeah are you are you
limber at this point are you stretched
out we should we should have you stretch
yeah i could i could probably stand to
stretch a little bit more okay how about
let's let's guess how many kicks it's
going to take i think i think one i
think one but but two at the most it
won't take any more than two yeah all
right let's keep indoors let's do it
let's get let's get to work here
check my angles guys check my ankles
make sure we got i've got a camera
inside as well to get the inside cover
oh okay so we got a wide there so you're
gonna kick it in but what's the story
like take us through because like let's
take us tickets to a place
all right how are you feeling right now
uh i'm excited it's a little close
okay yeah oh same you did it again
um i'm feeling i'm feeling good
um i'm not that warmed up i do want to
say
tell it to the folks at home yeah uh
folks i i do want to make this very
clear um that i never uh took martial
arts in my entire life what really yep
so that
[Laughter]
so what you're about to see is happening
in real time so you're not even a ninja
anything you think you're gonna be able
to kick the story uh ninjas don't kick
indoors for the record they sneak in
windows they're sneakier than that
they're much sneakier than that okay
this is more of a sort of a swat team
type situation yes i like that okay can
i ask a question
is it more fun if it's glenn kicking in
the door or do you want to play one of
those characters from the 80s meaning
you have a story and there's somebody or
something in that door that you need to
get to because you want to say something
cool after you kick it in you want to
come into the door into your camera in
there and announce something that's true
who are you looking forward to where's
the girl we live your dream here for
like um
yeah what's the what's the what's the
narrative you know where's the girl
something like that
that could that could be the villain or
the hero i don't know how do you get
your kicks
oh you want it to be like a one-liner
okay oh yeah yeah okay
let's go
it's just a great one boom let's go
because well i think also like commit to
it right so if it doesn't work once
don't stop like keep going until it
opens and you might if you wind up
putting a hole like through the door
you might have to bash through it like
the uh the the high c guy
yeah yeah yeah the cooling down the
kool-aid guys
oh yeah yeah that's what you should say
okay oh yeah oh yeah okay i'm sorry i
had someone else all right ready
everybody yeah here we go glenn's lined
up he's lined up
okay
okay here we go
come check this out uh
i mean let's grab the camera here you
went straight into the drywall
so let me get get a little shot here
into the drywall we made our stuff to
fix a hole so
oh my god
how do you feel right now glenn how do
you feel uh an exhilaration that i
haven't felt uh in in quite some time uh
an exhilaration having felt in quite
some time
michael's too close yeah okay
how does your foot feel
awesome what is good what else can we
break is this uh
we were uh sorry
sorry what's this one coming through
see people are trying to work people are
working hi emma this is where just broke
your door i'm sorry
well
so this one you will you don't want to
break the glass
but out here
again oh just uh for the for the creeps
out there this is the beautiful la
you've heard a lot about the uh the
rivers in la and uh this is one of them
this is the one earlier before we were
discussing kicking in the door we
noticed there was some real flimsy wood
and we were thinking gosh this was wood
that you could almost karate chop right
through
it's bendy really wouldn't even take
that
elbow maybe
there's another bar underneath it that
i'm afraid you could break but i wonder
if you could kick that
first well you could easily get through
it but now we're we're past talking
about kicks and we're in the chops yeah
i think you could chop through that
no no
there's a good chance there's not it's
not even yeah
it's popping up on the side but there's
a good chance you go to chop this
no
don't do that
i think you could chop as hard as you
wanted and you actually would not break
through this
oh see he's making it a challenge which
i understand okay i feel like what i
want to do though is remove this
because if you remove the i'm afraid if
you go through you're gonna chop so hard
that you're hoping you'll go through all
three pieces of wood
you need to put something on top of this
yes to absorb the blow although a ninja
doesn't i'm not a ninja well again that
glenn's not a ninja i'm not no and then
just don't do that it's too noisy
well
i think we've learned that this piece of
old
particle wood is too tough for the three
of us
what about that brick you think we could
smash the brick through it
yeah smash
your hand am i the one doing it
or i'll do it what's he doing i just
yeah that's breaking is that gonna work
it's like a hammer
oh the brick just bounced right off of
it
but but it did split through the wood
making it far more choppable okay all
right
okay this is exceptionally choppable now
yeah the brick
the brick did splinter it from the
bottom i mean the security is gonna be
here like at any time yeah any minute
right we're gonna get in trouble with my
right hand but these
all right
all right
we did it now you're not technically all
the way
back well this is the problem yeah so
can you
yeah
we tore it
we tore it
i mean this is what these studios are
made of
just that's sexual assault broken dreams
broken wood this is halloween people
this is hollywood this is hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
well we're back
well we've done it we've broken things
we've kicked things and um glenn how do
you feel wait
oh rob has pushed the button is closing
the door for the non-watchers
for the listeners of the listeners doors
closed glenn how do you feel
[Laughter]
he asked me in his creepiest voice
and he feels you know i think you know
honestly uh
it was that was exhilarating yeah right
that was a lot of fun um
i really enjoyed it uh
i did not in fact stay in character like
i promised because but then i i kind of
came out of character because i was like
that was too [ __ ] easy and then
then remembered i had a line and you
know so had that been my one take i
would have [ __ ] blown it but um
i would like to do it again
i would like to do it again and i would
like to do it again with a that was a
real
i wonder if it's just the fact that the
door is locked and a lock sort of
symbolizes no to you and you kicking in
that lock says no i will not be
constricted right but not be constrained
constrained by the law the laws of
physics america or america
uh city or this flimsy door
i am godlike you know like that's i
wonder if that's why i feel so good
yeah absolutely it would have been cool
to kick the door clean off the hinges
like that i bet it feels great
that would require the door to really be
bolted on both sides
from a physics standpoint
oh yes which i'm sure of the science
yeah no you know you're right glenn you
did a pretty impressive spin kick in the
episode oh yes uh
to try to
i'm sure he's glad you brought that up
um well sure yeah i mean listen i i
again you know as i made it clear
earlier i've never taken any martial
arts
class in my entire life and
the first time i'd ever attempted a spin
kick in my entire life
was when we did that bit
wow and i have to say like it it looks
pretty good oh i thought it looked good
i think the duster makes it look good
the dusting of the duster enhances
anything oh sure you guys can't give me
this
you can't get me this you gotta you
gotta you gotta credit the duster for
for my form on my kick
i don't know enough about spin kicks to
know well that's for what your form
whether it was good or bad i think it's
good i like that actually i think it
looks like a good spin kick yeah and i
think the duster i think both things are
true and enhanced duster makes it look
like it's nice because there are flaps
and leathers flying everywhere
yeah the leathers uh
this that section of this that whole
episode is
i think
the show at its finest
but we are arguing about the way
like we have a conflict which is that
there's we want to get past this locked
door yeah but then we have the same goal
but it even starts even earlier as
you're entering the bar right we're
arguing about you should have a very
specific goal that you're both aligned
with right and or aligned on and then
you and then you very quickly are
arguing about
something about how to achieve that goal
yeah who should be wearing the duster
and the just the added level of conflict
of
you know i think i'm going to try my
keys no that's not gonna work but what's
really funny is that
we're conflicted but we're in this
particular one we're not like really at
each other's throats about it which is
funny it's like a like mild conflict so
like i don't think you're thinking let
me try my thing when you're going back
and forth which is like you're there on
a mission but you one of you wants to
wear that you both think you you should
wear the duster and then okay let's get
back to the mission but wait both of you
are on the same page you've got to drink
the banana beers let's definitely drink
the beer and then we'll get back on the
same page and then you're looking around
right you're on the same team and then
charlie sees the door who lives behind
that door yeah
yeah that's another great thing yeah
yeah yeah and i was like what do you
think let's find out let's stop arguing
about and find out what lives
do you think a pirate lives in there
yeah was that pirate private stuff
scripted or did you guys just make that
up on the day
the key the key thing was scripted
because i wouldn't have had a keychain
in my pocket the key thing was scripted
and i i'm almost positive that was an
adam stein joke yes i think the pirate
joke was an atom i think no i think
that's what i think it was i think the
pirate joke was an adam stein
yeah yeah yeah yeah anything i think was
my was my idea oh it may have been
because i just remember thinking it was
so dumb someone would try their own keys
but also like kind of kind of made sense
kind of yeah it made just enough sense
that you're like well i guess it's worth
a drive sorry adam stein i tried to give
you credit yeah i'm giving him credit
for that for the credit for the arguably
the better joke which is the
pirate private um
mayor elizabeth reminded me of something
uh that i'd forgotten but there was a
background performer in the scene
who when we were banging ourselves
against the door fred had to keep giving
them the note because the person kept
doing the universal sign for that
person's crazy where you crank you crank
your finger in a circle and roll and
point it at the side of your head and
roll your eyes and
something no one has ever done ever to
describe someone who's crazy
that person's crazy all right
what is that meant to symbolize your
your your your brain is like tumbling
around inside your head like
yes yes it's like a [ __ ] cement mixer
yeah it's flipping over and over and not
where it should be
yeah and i remember that being one of
the first times that seeing a director
like have to
tell a background performer like hey man
take it down it's awkward watch yeah
it's all it's awkward well actually i
think the director's not supposed to
talk to it's got to be the ad right
that's what it was right so the director
has to tell the assistant director who
can tell talk to them that's a dg is
that a dj or is that a is that a
background artist rule it's a crazy ass
rule that makes no sense it's crazy
crazy ass rules that make no sense have
you guys seen uh the most recent news on
daylight savings
it looks like we're gonna do away with
it yeah or is that well voted
unanimously voted unanimously uh the
house it's not up to the house quite yet
it's not has not been brought to the
house so we don't know when that's going
to happen things started
with the house of representatives and
then went to the senate
am i crazy i think it goes from the
senate to the hat to the house
but i don't know
what things went from the house to the
side i would have thought that yeah i
would have thought the other way i would
have thought
that all four of us don't know house has
less power so then it goes to the house
then it goes to senate and then it
becomes a bill on capitol hill remember
that remember that yeah absolutely they
have an equal amount of power but each
individual member has less power because
that's right there's many many more of
them are senators
i
but okay this still has to pass that
and and i just read a whole article
about how we as a nation have done this
before in 1970 we did this what do you
mean for two years
we tried it and yes and it didn't work
and people were miserable the public at
the time overwhelmingly decided let's
get rid of it
and then two years later they're like
can we have that back please and it was
reenacted wait who the people the people
wanted
yes the people wanted it back
mostly it was throwing people off to be
getting up in the morning while it's
dark for such a long period of time but
it's darker now yeah when we wake up in
the morning yeah it was it's like
ruining people's uh circadian rhythms
[ __ ] your circadian rhythm i'm sorry
well that's getting rim's going to get
locked in yeah when you just stick with
it for a while that's sure that's what
wires it in right well we can also just
shift yeah it looks like it goes from
the house to the senate
yeah so then what happened why did the
so the senators just decided yeah we're
just going to do this right so now we'll
kick it to you
okay guys we're going to uh
this is a specifics lesson this is less
exciting than kicking doors down i know
yeah i think this is great stuff by the
way i like that people tune in um to get
this information yes absolutely that's
what's really well that's what podcasts
are
actually it's not even disinformation
it's just a lack of information yeah
yeah this isn't we're serving up zero
information there's no information being
served
um i i will say i saw some comments on
the the the uh we were posting
[Music]
we posted a clip i think this morning or
maybe it was i don't know
recently where we're talking about the
daylight savings thing and
i saw one comment on on there because i
do like to read some of those comments
and and one person was like
you know saying something like well no
no we do need daylight savings time
because it's important for the plants
and the animals to have
the maximum amount of sunlight
you know what i mean because if they
don't then it's going to affect like the
plant life and this
and then somebody commented below them
do the plants and animals know what time
it is
and they can write things down now and
put them out in the world yep and uh
just like us i'm not smart just like
yeah we can dude we can put things out
we have a major platform and we don't
know how the house is that it works
we're not smart i mean this is good
that's a revelation right there yeah
let's see what that we're not we're
discovering that we're gonna kick in the
door charlie was just suggesting that
some people should you kick in the door
i don't think something i don't know
when things go to the senate but can you
kick in the door
i know i've never seen you make that
face i've never made that face can i see
it again oh that looks like a puppet
version of you oh you can't he's making
it he's scrunching his face in a
amusing way
i might not know when things go to the
senate but can you kick in a door
well we had a lot of people trying to
kick in the doors of the senate uh that
was interesting yeah um we did that and
we did that
we're a nation of door kicker
what can we say
i mean i kicked in a door in the episode
prior right you did what was you did
yeah yes we just didn't see it happen
too well it was
the first time on the inside yeah the
first time we didn't see it the second
time when i come in in the dress you
know
that's right what do i say um uh
with somebody oh behold a man and all
his
glory yeah or something something um
if you really want to get into something
rob go ahead and needle glenn about uh
the drinking uh and what oh you know we
should do a listener poll we should do a
listener poll and for anybody who's live
listen to the podcast stupid don't make
you're gonna
put are you gonna slap another poll on
glenn well yeah he keeps falling you
dude
oh you're just as bad as our government
just all ah all these
i'm fascinated by you thinking that
you've you have this revelation you've
come up with this this like this
hangover cure that nobody's ever heard
of yeah and what is that rob but it's
what is it it's having a drink and then
drinking a glass of water wrong
you're already wrong right off the bat
and this is why and this is why i know
and this is why i know that your
argument's [ __ ] [ __ ] because
right off the bat you don't even know
you don't even remember
what my formula was okay what's your
formula
no i don't want to i don't want to tell
you anymore because you're just going to
find it
you don't want me to reap the benefits
i'm happy for you to read the benefits
so the problem is that you you know you
and you said the same thing earlier like
oh you you know you think you made up
the thing i'm not saying i'm the first
person to do it
i'm just saying i discovered it's your
method
no i just i'm saying i discovered a way
to get drunk and not get a hangover
that's all i said i didn't say i'm the
first to ever do it and no one's ever
done it besides me it's the word it's
the term discovery yeah that makes it
seem like it's and
you myself you were presenting it as a
revelation to us as if we
yes but you don't remember what it was
so you're ar you're saying it isn't but
you don't remember what it was
could you tell us what it is i'm happy
to okay uh you pick a
a clear liquor
i would argue vodka is better than
tequila but either one i think works
because they're both uh they have less
impurities in them okay
and you drink that you do a shot of that
and then you
like if you're at a party you drink a
bottle of water and then you do another
shot and then you drink another and then
you what you do is you carry around the
party you carry a bottle of water you
make sure you drink as much water as you
drink booze well you're actually
drinking
more water i'd say what like around 10
times as much can we rewind the tape
just so yeah you didn't say i said for
every drink you have you drink a glass
of water and that's not my formula
i'm lost
am i that am i being gaslit uh well no
no no no i'm being gaslit because what
is okay define define an alcoholic drink
only clear are only clear lickers are
out well first of all that's the first
time i've heard you say clearly i said
that on the podcast when i said the
formula
i don't know if that's true because i i
feel like i'm 100 i had to watch that
episode
it's got to be clean it's got to be
purer if it wants to get inside my body
okay so beside besides that the shoe the
shoes
yeah besides that you got it right yeah
i just like that you guys use that
button to close the door and now you're
in here arguing about your poles yeah
yeah yeah
i was trying to do a joke it didn't work
no i get to come back yeah you get to
cut that out again
no you don't keep that in there keep
that for yourself i just want to say i
just want to say though i'm not saying
that i invented it and nobody's ever
done it before i'm just saying i
discovered i discovered for myself that
that was a way of drinking and and then
in order to experiment with it i was
like jill you should try this because we
were going to a thing and she was like i
just don't wanna i might get i'm gonna
get a hangover and i'm like i have a
thing try this and then she did it yeah
and she was like oh my god
you know she had the right response
because she actually tried it not two
people have never [ __ ] done it
every single time i drink you drink
vodka recognize it you didn't drink any
water in the drunk episode i
recognize that the more water i drink
the less hungover i'm going to be
everybody in the world knows that but
that was wait so can you talk about your
can you talk about your hangovers that
you had after we recorded that episode
oh god
did we talk about this yet i don't think
so
they had it the worst
definitely yeah you got sick right just
because just because i texted you guys
so i i only know i had it the worst
because we texted with each other and
i don't i don't i mean i i knew i was
like actually i don't usually use it
charlie drank the most because you had
two beers yeah i had three beers you had
three yeah okay and glenn i don't even
know if you finished that one beer but
then rob and i just did the shots
well i i i mean again i wouldn't
part of the problem was i didn't eat
anything yeah well i just know that i
didn't eat anything i barely ate
anything i had like a couple of bites or
something and some potato chips but like
that's not you can't do that and have
seven shots of whiskey it's just
i was
annihilated i was surprisingly okay
which made me kind of worried like i got
up and did work actually the next day i
had to come and break down the whole
studio and like put all the mics away
and everything and it felt distinctly
like do you ever do that in like college
where you threw a party in your house
and then the next morning you had to
like be around the party stuff and it's
always like the worst when you have the
hangover and you're around this is the
smell of the old beard
but back but back when i was doing that
it was like you would be picking up
cigarette like the
red cups with like cigarette butts
remember when you like pick up a beer
that you thought was yours and you go to
drink it
that doesn't exist anymore right yeah i
guess it still does people are still
doing yeah
you can't smoke indoors well less people
smoke in general i think um i definitely
felt like [ __ ] the next day for sure but
i i i i always feel like crap after i
drink now mm-hmm uh and and always in my
life did that's uh you know yeah it
[ __ ] me up i i i had what basically
amounts to the flu
for the first half of the next day like
i i was not out of bed and even
remotely functional until about one or
two in the afternoon that's a shame
because you guys were you were so fun
both of you were so fun well it's it's
also like bourbon i i don't i don't i
don't know my body doesn't metabolize
bourbon well let's do the next one with
vodka okay all right [ __ ] it let's do
the next one with vodka or tequila and
we'll do the goddamn thing with the
water and i'm going to bring here's what
we're going to do
we're going to drink we're gonna drink
nine shots and you're gonna drink all
that water and then you're gonna wake up
the next day and you're gonna feel like
[ __ ] well nine shots how much water you
have no nine shots i'm with you there
i'm with you there that's just that's it
doesn't matter how much water you drink
if you drink enough alcohol it will
poison you well i'm with you there no
you i will yes i will concede that
absolutely i will absolutely concede
that but so what you're suggesting is
you just drink a conservative amount of
alcohol and then also hydrate and also
be on a full stomach
and then you won't feel as something i
can see where you're headed with that i
know you can't yes you know me very well
yeah i i know where you're headed with
that and i'm going to let you guys
battle someone else i'll have some
drinks with you i'm not i'm not drinking
nine shots no i'm saying [ __ ] this i
wouldn't i i won't
at some point my body will be like
see ya you think so yes now you got one
more you got
let's do one every uh you know every
month or so oh oh wow no no no no no i'm
joking i'm joking yeah once every couple
months
your liver's got that in it don't you
think
next time i'm gonna bring a breathalyzer
so we can see absolutely
because i bet i would have had the
highest just because my body weight
versus because i drank the same amount
but yeah right i was i should have
brought a breathalyzer
we saw someone on instagram posted that
they were watching the drunk episode
while giving birth like they were in
caitlyn reposted it they were in labor
this woman in labor and like on her
phone like well we're gonna have a st
patrick's day baby and like the podcast
was on the tv in the hospital
that's crazy it was wild
yeah oh my god you're changing lives do
you have a face do you have a face about
that
yeah yeah
that was a good one
all right
guys we're changing lives oh we are well
guys this has been fun uh thank you for
letting me kick in a door in your office
i really appreciate that i i really do i
sincerely appreciate that that was that
was fun yeah that was cool we'll make
sure ross gets the invoice
it's a union job so that's going to be
quite pricey
but we'll figure it out all right you
know what i just decided i'm not gonna
pay for it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]